[Music]
I'm curious to know what is coming up
for music okay so the big thing this
summer for me is summer live music being
outside listening to all this great
stuff and they're sure you're going on
yes very awkwardly oh so uh half of the
world I think was at Coachella a few
weekends ago two big stars from
Coachella are touring this summer we've
got Lady gaga on her Joanne world tour a
lot of people are very excited about
that
and Kendrick Lamar who killed it he's
going on to her so that's gonna be a
really really exciting show um a lot of
really big entertainers hitting the road
this summer we've got Bruno Mars the
weekend and actually ed Sheeran whose
new album just came out
now ad if you've seen him in the past
his last tour it was actually just Edie
by himself on stage with just a guitar
and a looping station and it was
incredible it was one of the best shows
I've ever seen I wanted to hear that oh
my gosh well you might have to wait
because I don't think he's doing it this
time around it sounds like he's going
into bigger production valueee doing a
really big show this time around and ET
actually caught up with him back when he
was launching the album and he gave us a
little taste of what to expect so take a
look at this interview I put a lot of
time time and effort into and it's going
to look impressive but in terms of it it
being a show I've always had to like had
the show with sort of b-sides from the
album and now I can do a show where it's
just hit singles which is something I
haven't been able to do before
thank you you so cute I love him and
that albums so good I don't know if you
guys are as obsessed with it
oh yeah yeah but I've been playing it a
lot lately I can't get sick of shape of
you I'm trying but I can't and they
overplay it on the radio yeah over and
over and over again yeah I'm not sick of
it either yeah yeah I'm going to
Barcelona sorry oh good run yes okay
well hopefully you'll be performing a
live this done now if nostalgia is more
your thing this is going to be an epic
to our New Kids on the Block are teaming
up with boys to men and Paula Abdul for
the total package tour
oh my god my 90 is loving hor he's kind
of freaking out oh my gosh well they've
been touring
a lot over the last few years and I
think this juror will be really exciting
especially because it's Paula's first
time out in 25 years she hasn't been on
the road in that long if you can believe
it and the guys we actually caught up
with them recently and we don't have a
clip to show you unfortunately but they
were really excited to be performing
with Paula because they talked about how
they really came up together in the
industry but there's been kind of a gap
Paula's met you know she did Idol she
has been doing her thing she hasn't
really been doing music yeah in a long
time so they're really excited to be
part of her comeback and they're really
proud I think to play a role and all
that with her so excited that everybody
from the 90s is finally embracing I just
make money doing that and they're doing
it it's amazing because we love it I
mean we're all eating it out yeah yeah
we go I won't spend a fortune I will go
into debt to go well there's another
exciting one coming up that I'll tell
you guys about in a minute but first I
want to get into the country music world
Sophie's heartbeat listen I love country
music and you know what we'll just talk
about it right now Florida Georgia line
they are going on tour with the
Backstreet Boys what a combo Nelly okay
you guys can you just process that for
one second no floor so FG always have
song with Nelly in the past and they
just did a song with the Backstreet Boys
gotcha mama and me they performed it at
the ACM Awards earlier this month and
they did the whole backstreet's back
dance and everything like it was
incredible so that's gonna be something
really exciting to look forward to and
they're playing like these iconic venues
they're playing Fenway Wrigley Stadium
so a Wrigley Field I'm sorry Oh sports
my not my forte okay elsewhere in the
country world we've got Sam hunt Lady
Antebellum Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
doing this old soul tour oh they're
amazing and then we've got festivals
really quickly I got a shout-out Lord
the festival Queen oh my gosh so she is
playing Bonnaroo Lollapalooza and
Outside Lands
hmm um when does she have time to
breathe never and she just is releasing
new music I think she's got an album
coming soon she just released a new
single there's a lot of other festivals
going on bottle rock up in Napa I'm
going Foo Fighters Tom
eight maroon 5 you are going I know
jealous I am going gonna drink a lot of
wine while you're up there look ha ha
you're also going to fireflies I'm going
to Firefly in Delaware surprise me I
didn't know how awesome this lineup was
but we've got Kesha which is really
exciting Bob Dylan Bob Dylan these are
30 Seconds to Mars right yep yeah so
that'll be a big one oh my gosh I cannot
wait how excited are you about relating
and then over in the UK Glastonbury is
always the big one of the summer
Radiohead Foo Fighters ed Sheeran so so
many more so that's all we have time to
talk about but I could go on forever
there's nobody there were so many
festivals if you want to know more about
what to expect this summer we are gonna
have a full list for you on ET
online.com and be sure to check us out
for all the latest in music movies TV
news whoa entertainment thanks guys oh
yeah guys more bye guys bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
you